climat une guerre américaine un film est
signé cédric tourbe avec nous pour
prolonger la réflexion sur ce paradoxe
américain gérard longuet bienvenue vous
êtes mineur à l'ère de la meuse premier
vice-président de l'opex l'opex et
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
damien carême bienvenue à vous également
vous êtes député européen les verts et
vous avez aussi était le maire de grande
synthe dans le nord pendant 18 ans
nicole bacharan et également avec nous
bien venu vous êtes historienne et
politologue spécialiste est des états
unis et denis olivennes est avec nous
bien venu vous êtes directeur général de
libération essayiste et vous êtes
l'auteur d'un étrange renoncement chez
albin michel merci à tous les quatre
d'être avec nous ce documentaire pointe
un paradoxe américain qu'on n'avait pas
forcément tous observés en tout cas moi
je ne l'avais pas observé les états unis
à la fois grands pollueurs et grands
investisseurs dans la recherche sur le
climat est-ce qu'il est réel ce paradoxe
nicole bacharan est-ce qu'on est dans
une forme de schizophrénie américaine je
sais pas si c'est de la schizophrénie
mais oui c'est tout à fait la situation
telle qu'elle existe il ya une passion
de la nature aux états unis depuis
toujours et c'est quelque chose
d'ailleurs qu apparaît très clairement
dans le documentaire il ya un
prolongement scientifique à ça qu'ils
sont toutes les recherches sur les
énergies renouvelables sur le climat sur
la manière de capturer les gaz à effet
de serre sur la protection de la nature
si vous voyez la côte californienne par
exemple il n'y a pas l'ombre d'un bloc
de béton donc c'est sont pas des choses
qui n'existent pas et par ailleurs vous
avez un mode de vie ultra consommateurs
en électricité moi j'ai grandi dans des
états unis eau moore est froide et qu'on
rentre et on plaît en plein été dans un
shopping mall ou autres les sens
évidemment pas cher les distances très
grande avec les voiles les voitures très
lourdes vous n'y voyez pas un paradoxe
vous disiez je fasse une schizophrénie
sait quelque chose mais les deux ne vont
pas très bien je ne vont pas très bien
senties quand on regarde mais les deux
vivent ensemble il ya aussi aux
etats-unis cette mentalité de chercheurs
d'or qui n'a pas changé de cette idée
que la fortune état
à porter mais quand je vivais au texas
est vrai que les pétroliers c'était
d'anciens rangers où le voile alors noir
avaient surgi du sous sol et quand tu as
quand a surgi là toute la sphère des gaz
de schiste moi j'ai ressenti que rien
n'empêcherait un développement maximal
parce que il y avait des américains avec
la fortune sous leurs pieds il n'y
renonce pas mais les deux vivent même
temps vivent plutôt mal il ya des choix
des choix à faire et je chante hermine
l'assumé il ya énormément de régions des
états unis très gravement victimes du
dérèglement climatique et donc là ça
change le dialogue et ses abords des
d'ailleurs dans le documentaire gérard
longuet ce paradoxe américain vous
l'aviez observez vous parlez moi on
observe en l'observant politique mais en
l'observant politique internationale en
politique étrangère des états unis il y
avait au moins deux cultures très typé
très contrastées assez conflictuelle
pour des rêves hérité ce qui n'interdit
pas légions d'avoir des passions
communes mais il ya une élite américaine
qui est en porte-à-faux deux d'une base
américaine alors ça on passe de boma
matrone dont on peut penser que ils sont
vraiment aux antipodes ont la différence
électorale n'est pas spectaculaire et
dans cet afflux le film que j'aie par
écouter le crayon à la main quand même
remarquablement fait pour montrer
justement les différences de
comportement les différences de culture
je voudrais évoquer juste une idée
l'attesté les états unis sont un pays
très fédéral où les gens qui vivent sur
un sol ont vraiment l'impression d'être
propriétaire de ce vol on le ressent
danse déconsidère voilà et considère que
ce qui vient de loin et en particulier
washington est forcément une agression
stupide conduits par des irresponsables
incompétent et hostiles
ou dans le meilleur des cas ces deux
européens quand quelle crise et j'ai le
plus loin je parlerai de rapports
mystique à la nature cette nature que
finalement dieu leur a donné
dont il peut le faire absolument ce
qu'ils veulent donner une prime oui mais
je voulais revenir un instant sur votre
idée du paradoxe que ce paradoxe n'est
qu'apparent ans c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui face à l'urgence climatique
si on exclut les climato sceptiques je
les laisse de côté il ya deux façons de
réagir à l'urgence climatique sont nés
chez matisse en extrême il ya ceux qui
considèrent et c'est une vieille
tradition intellectuelle
malthus au 19e le club de rome années 70
que puisque la croissance démographique
la croissance du pib sont des facteurs
d'émissions de co2 là la seule réponse
efficace et urgente c'est de stopper
cette croissance et la croissance zéro
c'est la décroissance et il ya ceux qui
considèrent ils sont plutôt disons de
l'école
schumpétérienne enfin des économistes de
marché qui considère que jusqu'à présent
l'humanité a toujours fait face à ces
défis par l'innovation et la technologie
et l'intelligence humaine voilà
exceptionnalisme américain la fameuse
formule des écologistes il peut pas y
avoir de croissance infinie avec des
ressources finies et contournée par ce
qu'ils disent il ya une ressource
infinie c'est le cerveau humain et sa
capacité d'innovation et donc pour
éviter la catastrophe
il faut pas arrêter la croissance il
faut en changer le régime et il faut en
gros que cette croissance consomme moins
d'énergie et que cette énergie soit
moins carbonée et pour ça il faut
investir massivement dans l'innovation
dans les technologies donc voilà c'est
explique pourquoi on a à la fois un pays
qui continue d'émettre du co2 et de
l'autre qui cherche une voie qui ne
serait pas celle de la croissance zéro
d'abord sur le documentaire que j'ai
trouvé très bien le documentaire parce
que effectivement ça apprend des choses
sur le parallèle entre l'histoire des
états unis la préservation de
l'environnement tels que l'équivalent de
la france en parcs nationaux protégés à
aux états unis ce qui est immense
et puis cette à côté ça ce poids de
cette on s'accroche aux libertés
individuelles et donc je préserve
l'environnement si ça vient pas empiéter
sur mes libertés individuelles et avec à
l'arrivée ce qu'on voit que c'est sur
les républicains ou démocrates qui
arrivent au pouvoir ils sont pro clima
ils sont contre le climat on a vu cette
alternance sur moi sur les derniers
présidents aux états unis mais aussi
tout au début tout début des premiers
présidents aux états unis et on nous
voit aussi le poids des lobbys
george bush vilain de l'industrie et son
vice président de l'époque on le voit
sentido documentaire vient de
l'industrie pétrolière et il ya donc ce
poids extrêmement important dans une
société très libérale aux états unis et
12 sas sas à jouer c'est ce qui fait ce
paradoxe pour moi entre les libertés
individuelles et de préservation
championnat le mans sud la nature on a
l'impression sera pas un peu orgueilleux
et c'est facile de dire ça vient de dieu
comme on l'entendait dans un
documentaire mais au mieux on a le droit
d'avoir une arme pour tirer sur
n'importe qui et que ce qu'est ce que
dit dieu dans ce problème là derrière un
autre paradoxe américain peut-être vous
nicole bacharan
je voudrais juste ajouter que dans ce
paradoxe américain dans cette
schizophrénie américaine que vous citez
il y en a il y en a une autre qui fait
partie de toute la configuration que
vous avez décrite c'est que dans les
états les plus conservateurs qui votent
donald trump dès qu'ils en ont
l'occasion je pense au montana l'alaska
et c'est leur rapport à la nature est
certes très fort mais il est aussi il
relève du mythe du fantasme ce sont
effectivement des états où il met en
avant la liberté individuelle
je suis chez moi on va pas m'apprendre
comment je fais face aux grizzlies et
les élites de washington n'y comprennent
rien etc sauf que ce sont des états
extrêmement subventionnés et dont le
mode de vie rural le mode de vie de la
chasse dépens sans arrêt de l'argent que
c'est plus du tout un mode de vie
naturel et n'en a plus que donc il ya
crise il ya une forme d'hippocampe je
pense qu'à une infinie de de dénis
d'ignorance volontaire si on va dire
assez
l'heureux trappeur ou descendants des
trappeurs aujourd'hui qu'ils dépendent
en grande partie de washington et que ça
coûte beaucoup d'argent à la
collectivité je pense qu'il ne le
croirait pas cette indépendance là elle
est quand même illusoire je pense qu'il
ya un autre débat que vous avez touché
du doigt je disais tout à l'heure des
croissants souvint technologie un autre
débat c'est que chez nous peut-être
moins aux etats-unis en tout cas de
manière beaucoup plus minoritaires il ya
une écologie qui veut changer la société
et mais dans quel ado projet elle a un
projet de lutte contre le climat mais
aussi elle a un projet politique
idéologique appelons le comme on veut de
sortir de la société de marché de
sorcières de la société de consommation
d'un d'un monde plus frugale enfin elle
plus radical en tout cas oui à une
utopie comme il ya eu au nom de l' de la
lutte contre les inégalités sociales
doit partir du 19ème siècle utopie du
monde communiste il ya l'utopie d'une
autre société pour lutter contre le
climat et puis avant d'occuper le
changement le chantre le changement
contre le régime
aux etats unis c'est presque aux états
unis il ya un peu ça mais il ya beaucoup
de grosses parties du mouvement en
faveur de l'écologie on vient de le
citer c'est sait comment changer le
climat sans changer de société oui on
comment produire plus avec moins et il
ya même dont les appelle les échos aux
modernistes il ya même des gens qui sont
très militant sur ce sur ce thème là
chez nous en europe c'est plutôt
l'inversé on va y venir les lélés
l'avenir
j'espère bien intéresse c'est d'avoir
cette comparaison entre l'écologie
française et l'écologie allemande je
voudrais revenir sur quelque chose qui
me paraît importante dépression
d'ailleurs de madame une femme
formidable universitaire madame masson
delmotte qui est connue puisqu'elle et
l'animent le le premier groupe du giec
et les vice présidentes c'est une
française qui aime notoriété
internationale
je suis pas sûr d'être son meilleur
porte parole mais j'ai retenu quelque
chose de très important il n'ya pas
d'inertie du climat c'est ça qui est
important ça veut dire que le jour où on
arrête de produire 40 gigatonnes de co2
dans anthropique par parents le la
situation redevient assez normal il y à
une inertie dans certains domaines mais
qu'ils sont minoritaires ça veut donc ça
donne raison à ceux d'isis pour investir
maintenant parce que on peut s'en sortir
je me tais c'est que la france est un
pour cent de la population mondiale
c'est d'ailleurs un pour cent des
émissions mondiales on sent un petit peu
petit quand on sait que la chine l'inde
et les etats-unis tous les trois c'est
la moitié des émissions on comprend bien
dans le film en tout cas c'est que la
protection de la nature a d'abord fait
consensus au sein des camps républicain
et démocrate puis la crise pétrolière a
frappé et les camps ont commencé à
diverger les premiers poussant à
l'exploitation du pétrole les second
appelant à la sobriété énergétique et
même à des taxes sur l'énergie regarder
sous l'impulsion du vice président al
gore
des démocrates proposent de faire sauter
un tabou
taxes et enfin l'énergie consommée par
les américains afin de les inciter à
plus de sobriété
bill clinton dévoile le projet de taxe
énergie en février 1993 mais cette
proposition va rendre les américains fou
de rage jusque dans les rangs démocrates
et le président clinton doit finir par
l'abandonner trop tard toutefois pour
éviter de subir une raclée mémorable aux
élections de mi mandat damien carême
c'est fou d'entendre ça alors que nous
venons de vivre une crise d gilet jaune
qui est parti à partir d'une taxe sur
l'énergie ça veut dire qu'en fait ce
paradoxe cette ambiguïté par rapport à
la nature on veut tous la protéger mais
dès qu'il s'agit de payer de mettre la
main au portefeuille a plus personne
c'est pas complètement ça
en fait quelle était la situation des
gilet jaune je suis allé en voir sur les
ronds-points à côté de chez moi et donc
j'ai discuté avec eux en fait sont des
gens qui ne pouvaient plus vivre dans
les villes où les loyers devenait
exorbitants donc qui ont été poussés
dans les banlieues donc ils ont dû
prendre une voiture parce qu'on a aussi
abandonné les transports la puissance
publique avait moins de transports
publics on a fermé des gars dans les
petites villes on a fait il ya moins de
transports en commun et du coup ils
prennent leur voiture dont ils sont déjà
une première peine où ils sont à
l'extérieur des villes et une deuxième
peine parce qu'on augmente le coût de
l'eau de l'essence donc c'était une
mauvaise mesure et sans compensation
pour ces personnes et vous entendez dans
le documentaire quand je vois qu'il ya
une taxe c'est une mauvaise
en france est encore frais aux etats
unis c'est vrai aussi chez nous à cette
trouille des impôts moi j'aime bien les
impôts je pense que c'est bien les
impôts faut payer des impôts parce que
si on veut des infirmières si on veut
des policiers si on veut des routes en
bon état si on veut un certain nombre de
chennai et des châteaux comment on les a
même pas en niveau de qualité
d'autres choix derrière donc il faut
l'augmenter les augmentations de
l'énergie va se faire coup par deux par
deux biais c'est de l'énergie qu'on
extrait qui va devenir de plus en plus
cher parce qu'elle plus en plus
difficiles à trouver quoi quoi quoi
qu'on en dise et puis les taxe qu'on va
mettre dessus qui vont s' est donc
comment on accompagne ces mouvements là
comment ne pénalise pas les populations
qui sont les plus en difficulté qui
souffrent le plus de ça c'est comme
augmenter l'énergie et c'est un projet
dans en europe en train de discuter sur
projet qui arrive au niveau européen de
taxer effectivement le chauffage est
d'augmenter donc sur la taxation sur le
chauffage est sûre et sur les carburants
très mauvaise idée qui sont ceux qui
vont payer plus bas que ceux qui vivent
dans des passoires thermiques dans des
hlm qui sont pas isolés et c'est eux qui
vont voir leurs augmentations de facture
chauffage donc il faut des politiques
publiques derrière qui accompagne de
manière gigantesque et qui relance
économique du bâtiment local productive
derrière qui crée des emplois pour
isoler ces bâtiments et c'est comme ça
qu'on arrivera à éviter des sprays
nature ou gilet jaune et ces mesures
répondent plus aux états unis avec entre
ses représentants qui perdent leurs
sièges parce qu'ils ont défendu l'idée
d'une taxe énergie parce qu'ils ont
perdu leur siège sur les sur une taxe
sur l'énergie au moins au parti
républicain ils sont pas allés vers on
va organiser ça d'une manière plus
harmonieuse et on va dire le
réchauffement climatique n'existe pas et
il ya des tas de gens qui ont envie
d'entendre ça parce que c'est tellement
c'est tellement plus simple al gore le
dit d'ailleurs très bien c'est tellement
énorme on va dire qu'on peut rien y
faire et où même que ça que ça n'existe
le retour du dernier mais voilà et ça
quand même beaucoup nourri la campagne
de donald trump en 2016 et en 2020 il a
fait un score absolument éblouissant
mais je pense que dans tout le débat que
l'on a il ya une dimension qui est
essentiel aux états unis importante en
france peut-être un peu moins c'est que
on a on a besoin de proposer des projets
qui font rêver et pas et est annick
centrale et consommer moins punis et
être plus petit et et renoncer à ceci et
cela ça ne porte pas une société et
c'est vrai que ce que devenir comme on
lirait
disais à l'instant tout 7,7 il faut
reporter l'énergie verte afin l'énergie
humaine veut dire le la capacité
d'invention montauzier verbal à
l'enthousiasmé ziti vers des projets
alors technologique ou autre même des
grands projets de protection de la
nature mais qu'il fasse un peu rêver
c'est vrai qu'on entend beaucoup de
critiques sur le levant ce pays six des
landes masse parce que ça coûte
extrêmement cher et qu'il ya que des
milliardaires qui peuvent y avait une
jeune femme qui n'était pas
milliardaires mais ça fait rêver c'est
comme la station spatiale internationale
on peut pas porter une jeunesse en leur
disant ben il faut laisser tout n'allait
plus prendre l'avion n'est plus mais la
protection de l'environnement évitez le
discours un peu négatif qui ne faisait
pas rêver d'une allumette je crois qu en
tous les cas on va au devant de grosses
difficultés parce qu'il faut pas se
cacher la vérité on n'a pas osé le dire
jusqu'à présent mais maintenant les
analyses économiques le monde tue encore
un rapport de jean pisani-ferry la
transition écologique telle qu'elle est
prévue là va être brutal aujourd'hui on
a déjà en europe un prix de
l'électricité qui doit être quatre à
cinq fois supérieur à celui des
etats-unis et il va encore augmenter
sous l'effet de l'augmentation du prix
du carbone fade et des taxes co2 il va
encore augmenter donc qui va augmenter
pour les ménages et on sait pas
d'ailleurs très bien les effets
redistributifs il va augmenter pour les
industries donc il va broyer la
compétitivité des industries où on parle
de désindustrialisation on va accélérer
la désindustrialisation est le seul
effet que ça va produire à mon sens
c'est de jeter les populations
européennes dans les bras des forces les
plus extrêmes est tout à fait climato
sceptiques donc moi je suis plutôt
partisan
de tout à l'heure dans le le le les
options je donnais entre
arrêter tout
essayé de mener des actions qui sont
compatibles avec la croissance je suis
plutôt partisan des actions qui sont
compatibles avec soin elle suppose de
faire des choses inattendues on les a
faites par exemple quand on a regardé ce
qu'on a fait des sacrifices ou pas parce
que dès que vous parlez de taxes je
passe je sacrifie sauper non pas des
sacrifices des changements de
comportements 10 ans ne sont pas
nécessairement des sacrifices je pense
pas que l'heureux je pense pas qu'il
faille que ayez que l'on choisit les
choses pas crois pas qu'il faille qu'on
a une stratégie de duty pendre du temple
solaire mais mais mais je mets quand je
vois comment on a été capable de
mobiliser des milliards pour accélérer
la sortie des vaccins en quelques mois
pour une urgence l'idée milk je me dis
que nous sommes nous capables de faire
ça pour
un milliard de
d'arbres dans la foule d'euros pour la
reforestation pour enfin pour augmenter
la puissance des puits de carbone
l'océan les sols de la forêt pour
accélérer l'innovation
là on pourra organiser la transition et
les changements nécessaires de
comportement des industrielles du
transport et des consommateurs d'une
manière qui ne soit pas brutal et qui ne
conduisent pas aux effets inverses de
ceux de ce que pour cela c'est un
discours positif effectivement
il ya un problème européen
moi je suis très européen de conviction
et j'aimerais profondément qu'il y ait
une action une présence de l'europe aux
blancs mondiale puisque j'évoquais tout
à l'heure le fait que l'inde la chine
les etats unis font la moitié les
émissions de co2 le jour où l'europe a
une position très solidaires et très
strictes ça fait bouger les partenaires
les chinois bougeront d'ailleurs parce
que c'est leur intérêt de survie dirais
presque de santé mais ils bougeront pas
très vite or actuellement et jeu car
elle ne pourra que le confirmer
nous sommes en france à la fois peu
émetteur de co2 je crois c'est 7 tonnes
par habitant mais gros consommateurs de
co2 parce que nous importons des
produits l'acier chinois par exemple des
véhicules d'asie du sud est qui sont
lourdement chargés en co2 et donc
l'hypothèse de faire un rappel à l'ordre
aux frontières pour les produits qui qui
qui repose sur le co2 ce soit du ciment
ou de l'acier un bras c'est bien vu
impérieux ça serait c'est bien vu sauf
que
l'allemagne n'est pas vraiment convaincu
parce que l'allemagne un excédent sur la
chine et ne veut pas compromettre ses
relations commerciales avec la chine
comme en plus pour des raisons que je
comprends philosophiquement elle est
très anti nucléaire c'est lié à
l'histoire et à sa densité de population
elle nous apporte de gaz russe tant
mieux pour les russes ils le vendent
mais le gaz russe c'est quand même une
machine à faire du co2 par kilowattheure
et ils veulent en plus que nous fassions
nous fassions plus de nucléaire ou là on
est 40 fois moins émetteurs que le gaz
est 100 fois moins que le charbon donc
l'europe devrait balayer devant sa porte
avant de donner des leçons au monde
entier on arrive à cette taxe carbone
européenne elle était présentée par la
commission européenne cet été dans le
plan fife forte fifty-five
taxes européennes carbone aux frontières
mais non la définirait des békés et puis
on a des liens du groupe politique l'a
défendu on a déjà nous fait un rapport
d'initiative sur la peña rapport
d'initiative les parlementaires et
pourra s'adresser à la commission pour
donner des orientations dans ce qu'on
pense qu'on voudrait de ce texte et on
n'a pas voté les écologistes parce qu'il
y avait l'histoire des puits de carbone
et on n'est pas d'accord avec des puits
de carbone
pourrait on pas d'accord parce que c'est
une technologie qui marchent pas et
c'est une fuite en avant enfin nous on
dit il faut résoudre
continue à émettre du carbone on capte
ce carbone qu'on aimait et on l'enfouît
quelque part et c'est des techniques qui
sont pas ses
efforts et des océans de ces taxes
carbone vous disiez
protégeant notre industrie parce que je
trais réagir à ce que la question vous
avez posez c'est est ce qu'on va nous
punir est ce que est ce que ça va être
punitif le monde attendait la france
c'est le pays qui consomme le plus de
psychotropes dans l'industrie on a perdu
deux millions deux cent mille emplois
depuis des années 80
les jeunes ils sont ils sont dans un
état psychologique à une légende qu'est
sorti donc là on va pas bien on va pas
bien alors que pour l'instant on a fait
un business aux yeux jeunes donc oui
mais peu de l'écologie c'est aussi
refaire projet de société a une capacité
de rêver en proposant bsca 6 mai mais
est ce qu est ce que rêver c'est de
prendre l'avion si oui bien sûr que
c'est important mais forcément il ya des
règles simples il ya un débat se faire
du vélo mais
si vous lisez ces l'anc ouvrage qui
s'appelle un étrange renoncement
gameplay on va on va mal parce qu'on a
renoncé à la croissance depuis 40 ans et
est le cinquième pays du monde par sa
richesse par habitant ya 40 ans on est
le 25e et ça continue donc c'est un
sujet et si on accroît encore cette
décélération on va pas améliorer ni la
situation des banlieues ces réactions du
chômage ni celle des classe moyenne
celle du pouvoir d'achat ni celle des
fonctionnaires les ressources du service
public ni le ras-le-bol fiscal parce
qu'on fera objet d'augmenter les impôts
et on va même accélérer l la crispation
identitaire parce qu'on n'est pas
capable d'intégrer des populations quand
on est à croire à 0,1 de l'écologie ne
fait pas rêver c'est ce que vous êtes
tous en train de dire à damien carême
elle devrait
d'ailleurs soit jamais mise en
application pendant vingt ans dans une
ville pauvre 28 % de chômage 33 % de
gens sous le seuil de pauvreté et ça
marche et des gens étaient heureux on a
recréé société et j'ai organisé j'ai
créé un camp de migrants de migrants je
suis le seul maire européen à avoir
ouvert un camp pour accueillir les
syriens en 2015 qui arrivait sur ma
commune ils étaient 2500 pour une ville
de 23 mille habitants et ben on a radié
le front national ils ont ils étaient
même pas aux élections municipales en
2020 ils n'ont pas été capables de faire
une liste et j'ai pas eu de mouvement
dans la population et on a rendu du
pouvoir de vivre aux gens on a on a
recréé société parce que les gens font
leurs produits ménagers eux mêmes parce
que les gens cultivent l'enfer parce
qu'on leur ment pas c'est possible à
l'échelle nationale sont montés possible
de bien sûr bien sûr culture du quick
halal autour de la table on est tous en
faveur mais on est aussi passion pour
les territoires
[Musique]
mais c'est possible à l'échelle
nationale ne pas penser aux avions moins
polluants à toute sorte de rêve plus
grand que être plus petit consommer
moins vous dites à kelowna prochain
1 c'est pas forcément un rapport direct
avec l'environnement mais c'est une
ouverture sur le monde c'est un projet
qui va au delà de soi même je crois que
c'est une des choses qui manque en
france c'est des projets qu'ils soient
pas juste soi même et ils sont tout
petit monde donc effectivement les
réfugiés c'est un accès à ce monde là et
avoir envie d'explorer la planète et
même d'aller plus loin et massa fait
partie des rêves qui l'interdît pas j'ai
eu des mesures vélo aux médias des deux
mais non c'est pas vrai en france
pourquoi on regarde les vies antérieures
alors qu'on a des idées qui nous met de
centre-ville à centre-ville et
d'habilitation à la mairie mais c'est
commençons par là que je veux dire c'est
que l'avion pollue c'est vrai alors
pourquoi on ne réfléchit pas les avions
qui épaulent j'y réfléchisse un avion
hydrogène sont chers nous emmène loin en
fait il a posé tellement de questions
force qui nous on est très très loin
vous en éloigner mais je vais vous dire
amener alors que joe biden vient vient
d'annoncer vous le savez peut-être un
renforcement des aides aux pays les
moins avancés pour faire face aux
dérèglements climatiques le film lui se
termine justement sur un doute autour
des intentions écolo du nouveau
président américain même lui le
démocrate n'irait peut-être pas aussi
loin qu'il le faudrait regarder
joe biden a promis de faire revenir les
états unis dans les accords de paris sur
le climat mais il a également fait la
promesse qu'il n'interdirait par
l'exploitation des énergies fossiles par
fracturation des sols il c'est que
l'amérique ne peut pas s'en passer
nicole bacharan c'est intéressant il est
passé au look ça où il est pragmatique
il suivait pas perdre les présidents des
états unis et il a il à 300 millions de
l'américain derrière lui et des intérêts
contradictoires ça nous ramène au début
la taxe carbone il ya un moment vous
avez toute une partie du pays qui vit
des énergies fossiles et c'est
extrêmement difficile de trouver le
moyen de changer l'industrie le mode de
vie les revenus c'est des salaires
s'était dit
on y voit presque est ton nom écolo pour
pouvoir plaire à sa population est
convenu dans l'accord de paris l'avait
promis ça il l'a fait je crois que ses
intentions sont pas ne sont pas suspecte
mais c'est juste extrêmement difficile
extrêmement difficile à organiser
ce qui pousse aux états unis ce sont les
catastrophes annuelles la californie qui
brûlent les glissements de terrain les
ouragans qui se multiplient la floride
est un super conservateur on souffre
tellement que néant il ya un mouvement
quand même dans la population avait même
dans la frange disons des chrétiens très
très conservateur un mouvement pour dire
dieu nous a légué la planète faucon la
tranche mme est en bon état à nos
enfants donc les choses peuvent bouger
mais c'est entre ça et elle a échangé un
mode de vie qui a été fondé tout
l'expansion est fondée sur l'énergie peu
cher c'est très difficile parce que
quand même ceux qui payent le plus fin
pour ceux pour qui c'est le plus
douloureux ce sont les populations les
plus modestes les populations plus
fortunés elles peuvent se débrouiller
même si le prix l'énergie change denis
olivennes tout cela donne l'impression
que tout est entre les mains du
politique est seulement du politique
alors que le citoyen peut faire bouger
les choses la justice peut faire bouger
les choses bah les citoyens jouer les
les lcc venu à la conscience des
politiques parce qu'il ya eu un
mouvement des citoyens moi je suis j'ai
plein de désaccord avec les verts je
pense qu'ils se trouvent dans leur
scénario parce qu'ils sont trop obsédé
par le changement de société mais en
revanche on doit le reconnaître que
c'est leur prescience leur combat avant
que quiconque s'en occupe qui a poussé
la planète à bouger en tout cas le monde
riche donc aujourd'hui les écologistes
sont en route nord et les gains les plus
forts qu'on puisse faire sont au sud
donc ça pose un problème et je veux
fermer cette parenthèse mais met donc
non c'est les citoyens qui pousse
ensuite il faut great attenberg par
exemple a joué un rôle décisif dans dans
l'urgence dans le lait prise de
conscience de l'urgence climatique mais
je trouve qu'elle pose les bonnes
questions mais qu'elle apporte de
mauvaises réponses donc après il faut
que les pouvoirs publics
et c'est d'élaborer des réponses qui
rendent compatible
l'exigence de faire face aux risques
climatiques et l'autre exigence qui est
de continuer de développer une activité
qui permet de générer du pouvoir d'achat
de l'emploi etc etc c'est à dire
continuer à faire plus mais avec moins
d'énergie et moins de carbone beaucoup
moins d'énergie et beaucoup moins de
carbone et c'est cette voie ça c'est le
rôle des politiques et des experts mais
en revanche la société civile doit
continuer à pousser pour que les
solutions soient prêts sinon c'est
l'inactivité ou l'inaction qui sera la
règle gérard longuet vous avez le
sentiment vous qu'il ya ce décalage
entre un mouvement citoyen une envie
citoyenne une évolution des mutuelles
des mentalités au niveau des citoyens
plus qu'au niveau des responsables
politiques
moi je peux parler que de la ma famille
politique je reconnais qu'elle n'a pas
investi intellectuellement suffisamment
dans la réponse dans la solution à
l'inquiétude climatique
elle n'a pas pris position
dans le scepticisme
l'a épousé les idées convenues mais
jacques chirac était parfait sur ce
terrain la maison brûle et on détourne
son regard mais elle n'a pas apporté
comme les investisseurs américains
privés le montre aujourd'hui la
démonstration qu'on pouvait faire
quelque chose parce que d'abord on avait
une assez bonne conscience à juste titre
parce que notre énergie électrique et
est décarbonée et puis la
désindustrialisation a fait qu'on a
repoussés ailleurs des difficultés qu'on
aurait dû gérer chez nous aujourd'hui
moi je j'attends vraiment de ma fille
politique avec ses a priori avec ses
préférences avec son choix pour la libre
entreprise pour l'investissement privé
une certaine méfiance sur les
dispositions trop de rang général à
compatible de d'apporter de d'avoir
cette attitude
d'écologie de développement d'écologie
de solutions et 13 solution bon
il faut être lucide la transition
coûtera de l'argent et ce que l'on
investira à gauche on ne pourra pas le
dépenser à droite c'est une certitude
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que ce
n'est pas un comble c'est pas la guerre
de cent ans nous ouvrons s'il ya un
effort massif c'est un effort d'une
génération c'est ça sera beaucoup moins
long que la le mur de berlin il rideau
de fer on s'est tapé de 45 à 90 c'est à
dire pendant 45 ans il
s'est tapé une division bi polaires du
monde avec l' angoisse permanente d'une
guerre nucléaire là on se fait 40 ans
d'efforts on diminue et surtout à partir
le monde la tendance est bonne on
diminue l'inquiétude et on recrée de
l'espérance damien carême s'avoue préfet
presque plaisir d'entendre que un homme
de droite disent bas effectivement à
droite on a peut-être été un petit peu
lent alors on a créé la non mais on
avait un argument fort bidasses xv le
premier ministre de l'environnement
c'est pompidou qui l'a mis en place tels
l'excellent monsieur jarre au maire du
creusot je crois et qui était comme le
maire de grande synthe un très bon maire
local il est peut-être passé à côté de
la dimension des enjeux damien carême
non mais c'est mieux que ce soit
quelqu'un de ma famille politique il
avoue que moi qui le 10 mai mais voilà
je pense que c'est on est en retard et
moi je pense que les citoyens sont plus
en avance que les décideurs politiques
sur les décisions à prendre on l'a vu
avec la convention citoyenne et ce qui
nous attendait la convention citoyenne
c'est une map les entrées fait moins de
plaisir faire respecter le parlement
dont vous faites par ab lui non mais je
reste ou non mais je sais pas moi qui ai
créé l'exercice suit l'ont fait suite au
conflit des gilet jaune il a été décidé
de faire cette expérience entre
guillemets enfin ceux de cette mise en
place comprend 150 citoyens qui sont pas
qui ressort au sort parmi les
volontaires n'ont qu'en allemand sort
moi je connais des gens qu'on aime non
non je connais des gens qui ont écrit
sur qu'ils savaient pas qu'ils allaient
gadret et encadrer sa conviction trésor
est certain
il n'était pas concerné par l'écologie
et quand ils sortent à la fin d'un vol à
skis bon moi je me dis que quand on fait
cette approche là comme j'ai pu le faire
moi comme je le fais à travers la france
quand je vais intervenir un peu partout
pour parler de ça les citoyens se
demandent des choses même sur la
question des migrations quand je vais
partager l'expérience que j'ai vécue
localement moi je suis pas sûr des
français qui sont aussi le même quand
les gens de l'extrême droite dans la
salle il ne m'agresse pas parce qu'ils
n'ont pas ils n'ont pas de prise sur ce
qu'on dit parce qu'on le on l'a vécu on
l'a fait et je pense qu'on peut les
citoyens français sont beaucoup plus en
attente de solutions qui vont entraîner
pas des pas des sacrifices moi si je
vois pas ça comme des sacrifices un
autre mode de vie mais un autre mode de
vie qui soit joyeux mois les collègues
pour moi l'écologie c'est les joyaux
comment ah ouais vous les citoyens sont
très vite d'autres à partir du moment où
les politiques prennent les bonnes
décisions c'est à dire qu'elle laisse
personne de côté comme c'est le cas où
il ya des gens qui sont de plus en plus
pauvres citoyens qui est bien pour moi
excusez moi mais qui est jeu léger et
merdes enfin président de l'association
des maires des villes et banlieues de
france donc partout en france où ça va
mal j'ai voilà on était les maires on
réfléchissait avec un comment on s'en
sort de ça
quelles sont ces villes là c'est des
villes de relégation où les gens il
souffre de la malbouffe du mal logement
d'aidé mauvais transports publics etc eh
ben il ya un effort à faire considérable
dans ce secteur là pour enfin voilà pour
rendre à ces personnes-là de la dignité
rangs du pouvoir ce que j'appelle pas du
pouvoir d'achat mais du pouvoir de vivre
c'est à dire que oui ça rend parce que
quand on fait une rénovation énergétique
dans son logement eh ben on a baissé
facture énergétique et à alès des moyens
pour faire autre chose à ces familles là
mais ça préserve aussi notre
environnement et ça génère de l'emploi
derrière il ya plein de choses à faire
qui nous permettent de mieux vivre en
bonne santé aussi parce que quand on
mange mieux quand on vit pas dans des
passoires thermiques qui causent des
maladies derrière tyson politique pour
manger mieux est ce que ce n'est pas une
question ah bah oui parce qu'il y en a
quand même des politiques agricoles et
de gaz ils sont là qui colle comme une
épreuve qu'il te faut qu'ils
m'aideraient de savoir et loriot qui on
oriente les subventions du tueur et de
préférence moi je suis en effet c'est en
ne sait pas on apprend qu'on transmet
pas de bons comportements de vie parce
que la france s'est déraciné pendant les
trente glorieuses on est passé d'une
population qui était rurale et agricole
dans les années 50 à 40% aujourd'hui
c'est 4% le monde urbain que vous
évoquez c'est un monde nouveau qui n'a
pas de tradition qui n'a pas de culture
qui n'a pas encore de complètement de
savoir vivre les petits pavillons loi
loucheur ça existe mc ultra-minoritaire
les grandes bandes de la caisse des
dépôts cdc km en ce moment et on les
jeunes saumons ne savait pas comment
vivre et on n'a pas su parce que dès
qu'on a pu les kits et on les a quittés
un tout petit mot pour conclure denis
olivennes puis nicole bacharan peut-être
sur esque de toute façon on s'en sortira
sans les etats-unis denis olivennes je
crois pas qu'on s'en sortira sans les
états unis je pense que les états unis
vont rejoindre progressivement de
mouvement j'aimerais claque commises que
lequel l union européenne soit à la tête
d'un mouvement de mondialisation du
sujet donc deux programmes marshall
parce que j'insiste sur un point je
finis à la dessus il faut penser qu' il
ya des milliards d'êtres humains sur la
planète qui n'ont pas accès aux routes
qui n'ont pas accès aux hôpitaux qui
n'ont pas accès ou un revenu minimum et
cela si on casse la croissance on l'est
on les livre on les condamne
définitivement et eux leurs aspirations
première c'est celle là est donc notre
première priorité devrait être d'agir de
2,2 de consacrer des sommes
considérables des pays du nord vers les
pays du sud pour leur permettre eu de se
dé carbonée rapidement ce qui aurait un
effet de levier énorme sur le niveau
d'émission de co2 et qui leur permettra
en même temps d'enfin qui éviterait de
les exclure du banquet entre guillemets
du monde actuel donc et les états unis à
mon avis partis participeront de cette
opération mais je vois que c'est
l'europe qui devrait en prendre le
leadership parce qu'elle a plus
conscience sans doute que les états unis
aujourd'hui de cette nécessité nicole
bacharan oui je pense que c'est tout à
fait juste et en même temps je ne vois
pas comment on pourrait s'en sortir sans
les états unis et sans la chine mais il
faut aussi ces deux géants et de
l'industrie et de la pollution ne
suivent pas le mouvement je ne vois pas
comment on peut vraiment avoir des
mesures efficaces et je pense que 1 des
difficultés contre 100 en france mais
dans le monde entier sait que c'est vrai
que citoyens sont tout à fait prêts à
changer un certain nombre d'habitudes
tout à fait demandeurs mais ils savent
bien que l'essentiel du problème c'est
d'être un problème industriel c'est la
pratique des industries et c'est là
qu'on a besoin de mesures qui soient
internationale pour qu'il n'y ait pas
sans arrêt le problème posé à mais oui
mais je vais désavantagés mon industrie
- industrie locale c'est vraiment au
niveau industriel que ça doit bouger
parce qu'en effet les citoyens ils ont
depuis longtemps rejoint le mouvement
même si on n'est pas tout à fait
d'accord dans la manière de le faire oui
il faut changer certains comportements
et les gens le font et on s'arrêtera là
merci infiniment à tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à cette émission je
rappelle le titre de vos livres un
étrange renoncement que vous avez déjà
cité veniez olivennes aux éditions albin
michel est le vôtre les grands jours qui
ont changé l'amérique le vôtre ainsi que
de dominique simonet aux éditions perrin
merci beaucoup fin de cette émission se
retrouve très vite sur public sénat
[Musique]